Okay it's time for some boxing gloves
table tennis
Not bad!
Emil catch
I actually caught it!
It actually stayed there!
I think it's time for you to also take one
Let's see how it goes!
Just a normal backhand
What else than a lucky point!
You get a lot of sidespin
In the next episode we are going to take challenges from Instagram comments,
so if you haven't followed us there, remember to do it!
And we've also got a lot of exclusive
stuff for you guys,
so check it out!
The next challenge is to play with a 50
kg dumbbell
so let's hit the gym!
Oh there we go: 47,5 kilograms
Can you lift that?
That's almost as heavy as me
This is so heavy!
No, I can't!
So here we have it guys
47,5 kg. Just over 100 lbs
I think this is the heaviest racket I've ever played with
Otto! You have to do a 360!
I would cheer now but i can't
Almost got a point!
It's Miikka's turn to try
I think someone's gonna get hurt
Just don't drop it!
No I won't!
I've got a different approach
I went for the short one
Next we'll have a visiting star in this episode
He's the voice of table tennis, Adam Bobrow!
Let's go play some rallies!
Net post and in!
Did I make Pongfinity?
If you enjoyed this video and haven't subscribed to Pongfinity
Subscribe here or watch their other fun videos here
And if you wanna see more of Adam in action
go check out his channel here
Until next time!